on la cultive la collection dont la
savoie or même mais le plus difficile
c'est de la peindre la rose prend vie
sous le pinceau de florence berceau
aquarelliste botaniste elle peint toutes
sortes de plantes mais surtout des roses
peindre des fleurs et des plantes en
général c'est je pense un atavisme
familial puisque mon père lui même et
sortent de l'école d'horticulture de
versailles j'avais une grand mère qui
était passionnée par les fleurs et qui
était toujours dans son jardin et maman
aussi a pris la suite elle a un très
beau jardin et je pense que j'avais un
oeil déjà un peu éduqués pour pouvoir
apprécier l'aquarelle des fleurs
la petit bouge plus je bête
alors je vais jamais au crayon je
commence toujours par faire par dessiner
avec de l'autre jaune
je suis en train de tout placé pour
avoir des points de repères je la
construis aussi par rapport aux sombres
et au clair enfin c'est vraiment la
chose la plus importante parce qu elle
est très claire
des fleurs blanches c'est que avec la
lumière qu'on travaille
une course contre le temps oui parce que
lafleur s'ouvre elle est vivante comme
je dis c'est un peu à contrer entre nous
deux bon on est toutes les deux sages on
est toutes les deux appliquée elle à
faire son travail de s'ouvrir et moi à
peindre et puis moi aussi une certaine
sensualité je pense on peut pas nier ça
avec le pinceau les poils du pinceau
l'eau qui coule
c'est une relation très forte et on a
l'impression en tant que peintre de lui
retirer un petit peu quelque chose parce
que déjà là maintenant quelques heures
après elle n'est plus la même que ce
qu'elle était quand elle était dans
toute sa beauté il ya quelques heures
donc on lui a arraché quand même quelque
chose pour le restituer et le garder et
le posséder
moi je joue je pense qu'il faut qu'il ya
un petit peu de hasard est un petit peu
de rêve dans une peinture botanique et
peut-être cet éphémère et je me dis
voilà encore une année préfère attendre
toute une année avant qu'elle revienne